meine these ist nämlich deutschland ist
ziemlich kinderfeindlich und dass das
zeigt sich gar nicht erst seit der
pandemie das zeigt sich schon viel
früher das zeigt sich in absoluten
kleinigkeiten waren sie schon mal mit
kindern im restaurant haben sie da
willkommen ich muss mal gefreut dass sie
kommen meistens gibt es eigentlich nur
augen rollen und so ist es für eltern
und sie wissen nicht so richtig sind wir
hier bekommen sollen wir wieder raus
hier in berlin gibt es cafés haben
poller damit der bloß kein kinderwagen
reinkommt jetzt habe ich dieses video
gesehen es geht gerade auf instagram
durch die decke mehrere zehntausend
menschen haben sich das angeschaut ich
zeig dir einmal
ich könnte jedes mal kotzen wenn ich ins
restaurant reinkomme und sehe wie so ein
kind am ipad ist jedes mal wenn ich das
sehe könnte ich im strahl kurzweil ist
das schlimmste was einem kinder gehen
antun kann ist möglich sehr kleine
kasten aber jede maus club wenn man sagt
kinder müssten wir einen computer lernt
bullshit da alles klar
ja wissen sie was ich finde es auch
nicht so wahnsinnig tolle meine kinder
vom ipad setzen aber ich will sie einmal
mitnehmen in die situation die eltern
ins restaurant gehen wenn kommt der ein
mann kommt mit den kindern alle drehen
die augen schon nach oben und hoffen
dass man sich nicht in die nähe setzt
und dann hofft man natürlich so sehr
dass die kinder sich benehmen ruhig sind
oder mein lieblingswort funktionieren
und das tun sie dann natürlich überhaupt
gar nicht das freut natürlich alles nach
hinten los eltern kriegen schweißperlen
auf der stirn und hoffen nur dass die
nudeln einkommen dann kommen die nudeln
endlich die kinder sind überall die
blicke werden immer böser und dann
staatswohl steigern und so geht's eltern
ja es ist zum kotzen wenn die kinder vor
so einem ding setzen aber manchmal
eltern gar keine andere wahl weil wir es
nicht geschafft haben eine kleinigkeit
ein normalen restaurantbesuche für
eltern in irgendeiner art und weise
angenehm zu machen und ich möchte jetzt
hier auch diese frage mal einen tisch
tragen ich bin sehr gespannt wer von
denen die hier mit an unserer
diskussions tafel sitzen schon mal
richtig mit den augen gerollt haben im
flieger oder im restaurant wenn eine
familie mit kleinen vielleicht auch
richtig schönes lernen kindern rein kam
sicherlich obwohl ich selber
achtjährigen sohn habe und diese ganzen
semester auch gemacht habe aber sobald
das kind dann aus diesem alter raus ist
wo es schreibt findet man sich dann
plötzlich selber an der situation wieder
wo man dann merkt dass man genervt ist
das will ich ganz leugnen
was die situation im restaurant angeht
würde ich immer eher so eine nintendo
switch empfehlen
[Gelächter]
aber grundsätzlich würde ich dieser
diagnose schon absolut zustimmen dass es
so eine sicherlich besonders auch in der
deutschen gesellschaft eine latente
kinderfeindlichkeit gibt die spürt man
ja überhaupt nicht wenn man weiss ich
nicht in mediterranen ländern zum
beispiel
und das hat sich halt in der pandemie
jetzt auch noch mal auf eine ganz
unangenehme art irgendwie kondensiert
man gar nicht mehr richtig was die
momentan jemals wieder rauskommen will
also was da eigentlich in den letzten
zwei jahren passiert ist es tatsächlich
finde ich wirklich historisch schlimmer
und ich finde jetzt in einer besonders
verfahrenen situation weil die kinder
die ganze ketten und gegenstand von
gewissermaßen verbitterten kultur
kämpfen sind also es gab lange gar kein
bewusstsein dafür wie kinder unter der
panini unter den panini
maßnahmen auch gelitten haben vor allem
der schule jetzt wird diese ganze
bewegung laut was vorher schon davon
gesprochen die alle sagen oh gott unsere
kinder werden in der schule durchseucht
wir müssen jetzt vor dem virus schützen
wir dürfen die schulen nicht wieder
aufmachen aufmachen
es ist eine völlig verfahrene situation
wassermassen die kinder zwischen die
fronten von von absoluten ideologischen
konflikt geraten sind und wo es ja weiß
ich nicht wo man sich wirklich erst mal
ganz neu sortieren muss um wirklich zu
schauen was ist da eigentlich alles
schief gelaufen und wie kann man da
wirklich was an der situation verbessern
ich finde die panne hat es so unfassbar
entblößt ich finde nur dieses kleine
beispiel dass ich gewählt hat zeigt dass
es teilweise so leicht wäre auch dinge
zu ändern also ich sitz ja auch nicht im
restaurant und freue mich über jeden
nachbartisch also da sitzt vielleicht
jemand der cloud oder dann sitzt jemand
der redet laut oder
der mensch um die masken auf dem tisch
so widerlich wie menschen also ich hab
wirklich ich habe übrigens würde ich
sagen ich freue mich mit den augen bei
kindern aber
mast wenn menschen dann am nebentisch
diese maske am arm am besten noch haben
oder um den hals tragen während man ist
oder auf dem tisch liegen haben das regt
mich fürchterlich auf und da habe ich
zum beispiel habe ich eine ganz kurze
zündspulen wurde dann kann ich gar nicht
aber wer geht ihr denn alle also philipp
abenteuer ich meine ja also ich habe
meinen augen gereizt innerlich war
innerlich vielleicht
aber es gehört ja zur wahrheit ich
glaube da geht es eltern sowie politiker
in die fußball bundestrainer jeder der
dann als dritter auf die situation guckt
sagt dann wahrscheinlich ganz leicht das
muss er jetzt nicht sein das kind
dadurch ein ipad im restaurant mein
vater ist man eben ohne kino als
zurückhaltend als frommen wunsch für die
eigenen kinder irgendwann mal mitnehmen
dass sie auch nicht mit dem ipad im
restaurant
aktuell ist aber zur wahrheit gehört
natürlich glaube macht es sich da oft
ein bisschen leichter und das zeigt ja
auch glaube ich dieses video man fragt
sich so ein bisschen ist die empörung zu
recht sieht so ungern ist es eigentlich
ist eine diskussion die man aus
vielerlei sicht sehen kann und ich
glaube auch man muss einfach da müssen
wir auch in der politik glaube ich einen
klaren blick dafür auch haben daheim
das wäre ganz kritisch aber zum thema
kinder das finde ich ganz gut hat einer
meiner amtsvorgänger aus mecklenburg
vorpommern der hat nie die große
bekanntheit gehabt hat aber meine gute
rede im bundestag gehalten wo er gesagt
hat kinderlärm ist zukunftsmusik finde
ich ganz gut dass es irgendwie so
politisch glaube ich in sound den man
sich auch ein bisschen in deutschland
begleitet ja das stimmt hier aber sollte
man die gleiche musik und deutlich
widerspricht sich rahmen der schweiz ist
natürlich eine ganz ganz ernsthafte
frage stellen und mit dem wir jetzt da
konfrontierte die kinder und die frage
ist ja was ist schlimmer was ist die
schlechtere variante wenn du kinder hast
die in einem restaurant oder auf besuch
herumrennen alles herunterreißen und
dann lässt man die gewähren oder
herumschreien ist das besser oder
schlechter als wenn sie ruhig hinter
einem ipad sitzen und zwar die frage ist
nämlich wirklich sehr relevant die sie
bringen nämlich was ist die
verantwortung der eltern und ich war die
wichtigste verantwortung nicht ab kinder
und mein kleinster ist zweijährig der
kommt jeden morgen um 23 uhr morgens und
der wille qualität times mit bild besuch
und da sehe ich mich manchmal nach dem
ipad aber der mit dem ipad
erstaunlicherweise noch im büro ist
was ganz wichtig ist weil ich oft schon
gesehen habe kinder die eltern die
finden das ganz toll in ihre kinder alle
ein riesentheater veranstaltungen in den
restaurants alle verringern sollte sind
auch kinder und so und ich glaube da
haben die eltern eine ganz wichtige
verantwortung die kinder durch so zu
erziehen dass sie in der gesellschaft
sich auch einfügen können das ist
nämlich auch viel später wichtiges und
terroristen hat
über stichwort unsere wenn irgendeiner
schon vorbei danke der zugeschaut haben
und bis morgen abend dann sehen wir uns
wieder haben sie noch einen schönen
abend des morgen
[Musik]